WASHINGTON, DC.
>> CAN'T SAY IT ANY BETTER.
THANK YOU.
STILL NO ACCOUNTABILITY FROM
TEAM BIDEN, OR HONESTY ABOUT
JUST WHY THIS WENT SO WRONG SO
FAST.
HERE ARE KAYLEIGH McENANY IS
WITH US.
WITH THE POINT, YOU EVEN TWEETED
, INCOHERENT, MUMBLING,
BUMBLING, STUMBLING.
HE CAN'T GET THROUGH A SIMPLE
PRESS CONFERENCE, WE'VE GOT A
PROBLEM.
EVERYBODY CAN SEE IT.
THE MAN IS A COGNITIVE MASSIVE.
HOW DOES HE STAY IN THIS JOB?
>> WELL, IT'S BECAUSE OUR
CONSTITUTION, OUR CONSTITUTION
DOESN'T ALLOW US TO HAVE THESE
TYPES OF ELECTIONS THEY DO IN
ENGLAND WHEN YOU HAVE A LACK OF
CONFIDENCE IN A LEADER.
WE'RE STUCK WITH THE PEOPLE'S
CHOICE UNLESS HE RESIGNED FROM
OFFICE AND THEN WE GET KAMALA
HARRIS.
THAT HAS TO BE INVOKED BY THE
BIDEN CABINET, SO I DON'T THINK
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN, BUT THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS ARE AMERICA'S
CORRECTIVE COURSE FOR HOW OUR
DEMOCRACY SPEAKS GREAT I THINK
IT'S HIGHLY LIKELY THAT THEY
WILL GAIN IN THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE.
BIDEN IS STILL IN CHARGE OF
FOREIGN POLICY WHICH IS THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE WE ARE SUBJECT
TO HIS JUDGMENT.
I THINK DEREK ASKED THE RIGHT
QUESTION, WHAT HAS JOE BIDEN
DONE RIGHT, IN THE ANSWER TO
THAT IS NOTHING.
EVERYTHING HE HAS TOUCHED IN
DONE HAS BACKFIRED AND THAT'S
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO JUDGE.
>> I WAS WATCHING THE KNIT GEO 9
/11 SPECIAL LAST NIGHT IN YOU
WERE ON IT IN THAT ROOM NEXT TO
THE CLASSROOM WHERE PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS INFORMED THAT AMERICA
IS UNDER ATTACK.
ANY LEADER AT MOMENTS LIKE THESE
.
KAYLEIGH?
>> I WATCHED YOUR INTERVIEW WIT
THE TWO GOLDSTAR DADS IN MY
HEART GOES OUT TO THEM BOTH.
WHAT THEY SAID SHOULD STRIKE
FEAR IN THE HEART OF EVERY
AMERICAN, WHAT THEY SAID AT
BASES IS THEY TALKED ABOUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN CHECKING HIS
WATCH.
WITH THAT SAID TO ME IS WHAT I
WAS PICKING UP FROM A
COMMUNICATION STANDPOINT AS A
FORMER PRESS SECRETARY THIS WEE
IS THAT OUR COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF
IS NOT COMPASSIONATE AS HE'S
BEEN KNOWN, HE IS CRUEL.
HE IS CALLOUS, HE'S NOT CARING,
HE'S CALLOUS AT BASE, THAT'S
WHAT THIS MAN IS GREAT I WATCHE
HIS ABC INTERVIEW AND HE SAID
WHEN AFGHAN FALLING OFF
AIRPLANES, THAT WAS FOR FIVE
DAYS AGO HE SAID NO ONE IS BEIN
KILLED, THIS IS AFTER MANY
AFGHANS WE'RE KILLED.
WE KNOW SOME OF THE HUMAN
REMAINS FOUND IN A WHEEL.
IN THE PRESS SECRETARY FOR PRIO
TO THE ATTACK WERE 13 SERVICEME
LOST THEIR LIVES WAS WHEN THEY
SAID THIS WAS EXECS US.
THIS WAS AFTER IT WAS KNOWN TO
ANYONE WITH COMMON SENSE THAT
AMERICANS WOULD BE LEFT IN THIS
COUNTRY STRANDED.
THIS IS AN ADMINISTRATION THAT
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH FOR THE
NEXT THREE PLUS YEARS.
IT'S HORRIFIC BECAUSE WE HAVE A
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF IT REALLY
SADDENS ME TO SAY HE SIMPLY DOE
NOT CARE